et pour bien comprendre cette mission
j'accueille l'animateur de découverte
bien sûr j'ai un cerveau soir bonsoir
charles c'est une première une grande
première n'empêche qu'il ya un bémol
parce que la sonde ne s'est pas fixé
qu'est ce qui n'a pas bien fonctionné
en fait quand il est arrivé à peu près
trois kilomètres à l'heure à la surface
elle pesait presque rien un gramme parce
qu'ils avaient presque pas de gravité
est normal morts deux choses auraient dû
se produire quand elle a touché le sol
des fusées aurait dû l'a plaquée au sol
six fusils n'ont pas fonctionné d'après
ce qu'on peut comprendre et en même
temps des arts port dû se déployer pour
bien fixer la sonde dans la surface du
sol du noyau et ça ça ne s'est pas
produit ce qui veut dire que la sonde
actuellement et d'après ce qu'on peut
comprendre très instable elle pèse
presque rien ne pèse donc un gramme sur
terre et pèserait sans sa 100 kg
mais là c'est ingrat mais ces grandes
communes une laveuse à l'aise alors tu
pousses un pimp sa part dans l'espace
pisi perdu si elle est ainsi elle est
instable
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça va vouloir
dire pour les expériences scientifiques
qu'on devait mener
il espère avoir une plateforme stable
sinon il n'aurait pas fait il n'aurait
pas prévu des harpons et ses terrains
donc l'expérience peut-être qui est le
point d'orgue de la mission de 2,7
secondes c'est de forêt profondément
dans le sol en moins 20 cm de profondeur
pour essayer d'aller chercher des
échantillons de matériaux qui sont
primordiaux qui remonte probablement à
la naissance de notre système solaire il
ya 4 milliards 600 millions d'années
pour voir de quoi il était constitué
notre système solaire quand il est né et
donc comment est-ce que notre terre a pu
se développer avec tous ces matériaux on
cherche aussi possiblement des molécules
de carbone complexe ce qu'on appelle les
bric constitutive de la vie vous et moi
nous sommes fait de carbone et ses
briques constitutive de la vie sont des
éléments qui sont des précurseurs de la
vie on pense que quand les comètes sont
arrivés sur terre quand ils ont bombardé
la terre pendant les centaines de
millions d'années au début de
la vie de notre planète elles ont
transporté l'eau des océans c'est pour
ça que nous avons des océans on le pense
et possiblement aussi ces molécules
prébiotiques qui aurait pu donner au
fonds qui auraient pu mettre la vie ici
ou lui donner à pied à l'étrier lui
permettre de déclarer des de se
développer sans s'être complètement
développé sur terre donc c'est important
de faire ses expériences
c'est vraiment fascinant charles mais
quoi qu'il arrive à filer le vaisseau
porteur lui
rosetta est toujours en fonction en
orbite et ça c'est merveilleux parce que
cette sonde est extraordinaire et même
si fida et ne peut plus continuer une
bonne partie de ces expériences parce
qu'elle n'est plus assez stable rezé a
continué rosetta va suivre la comète le
noyau de la comète
tout au long de son trajet autour du
soleil pendant des mois et des mois
ça n'a jamais été fait elle va voir le
noyau se développe et se transformer
tandis qu'il se rapprochera du soleil la
chaleur du soleil d'affaires fondre de
noyaux durs à plus de geysers de vapeur
d'eau plus de poussière qui vont sortir
pour former la chevelure de la comète et
former cette célèbre queue de la comète
et on va pouvoir savoir de quoi sont
faits tous ces éléments alors fila et
observe in-situ sur place de quoi est
fait la surface de la cobac et ces gaz
qui s'échappe mais mes résultats le fait
un peu à distance et donc pourra
continuer la mission de toute façon
alors on devrait savoir dans les
prochaines heures entre les prochains
jours qu'est ce qui arrive avec filet
actuellement il ya une fébrilité auprès
des scientifiques européens ils essayent
de trouver une solution pour fixer la
sangle au sol et continuer la mission
telles qu'elles avaient été prévues
on saura demain j'espère suivre à tout
ça avec vous j'espère merci beaucoup
charles du sud